hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to night shadows now this
might be okay well we're into it okay
cool
why are we here what I didn't even get
to do an intro I mean it's pretty
there's something what am i doing hello
Bob am I supposed to do something now so
I guess I could have done my intro hello
everybody this is night shadows and this
may or may not be a slender style game
which I haven't played one of those in
many many years maybe a year oh oh oh
we're in it now apparently okay we're
gonna forget that ever happened where's
they ignore the weird glowing Jeep that
I was driving over there and the weird
leaves falling out of hello oh now is
the intro oh okay this was highly rated
on gamejolt it was it was so I'm
assuming that there's a reason for that
and it's gonna get better later that is
actually really crazy because the leaves
if I'm not mistaken they're starting
about mid level of the sky a fictional
story oh really
I was it was true to life to me so far
okay
the starting a mid-life they're popping
up and then they're falling to the
ground
I have no idea what it's got a strange
charm to it I can't climb me okay the
Brawn stairs apparently let me try these
here yeah these were the stairs Dwight
okay bye it's all the back door unlock
the door to the radio station I did
excuse you I have no idea what's going
on this is a radio station oh all right
I see a red glow over here I'll I'll
just I'll be on my way placed on
Slenderman originally created by Eric
Victor Serge there you go so it is
Thunderman based it may not be a
Slenderman clone but it's based I think
so I hope I'm going the right way if I'm
not this is a long way to go I mean it's
good job replicating the giant fields of
nothingness with random hills was played
about it was rated good on gamejolt it
was rated good okay it was rated very
good I'm going to the red light I'm
assuming that the red light is gonna
show me exactly what I need to do
designer mapping and share pirard okay
3d models okay okay
where's my red Lego I have no idea it is
hot in this room and I'm starting to
sweat
[Music]
okay I think I made it finally after the
long journey of the weird field of
leaves that doesn't make any sense at
all I've arrived at my destination the
radio ty can't go up that hill I'll go
up the side thank you this is much more
better I'm going up now to the Radio
Shack hello somebody here alrighty then
oh hey did you do it where am i I can't
remember how I can't remember what the
hell's happened oh I'm playing now leave
me alone I'm trying to don't ask me to
do things I'm already on the way to do
what the hell is going on here so
bizarre hello are you oh oh hey you're
over there okay well I'll just be on my
way
hello you're just like oh excuse me I
need to get this excuse me excuse me
thank you sorry sir I can't believe this
I cannot believe this is so cool it's
not cool but I mean it's so cool and oh
hey it's got this weird that is a big
page Wow Wow
like honestly wow he's almost on my ass
what the hell is happening here all
right damn it meets hang on there I got
it
I am amazed in every way this might just
be the greatest game I have ever played
on earth it is by far the best game I've
ever played this is so silly and so cool
who drew that one what was that that
wasn't even a page what the hell [ __ ]
Jesus
I saw his arm he's like whoa he's like
right there he's like right on my junk
hey could you stop stepping all over my
junk
please mr. Slenderman I can't run any
faster he is like look his arms oh he's
right there he's right on my ass oh my
god that's so cool that's so silly this
is the greatest pleasure man game I have
ever played in my entire life this is
literally the best happy he's so close
to me I can feel his breath on my neck
from his not mouth he's due dear oh no
he's actually far behind oh no he didn't
stand so close to me oh god where am I
even going I have no idea what's
happening I am I am literally amazed I
am I'm literally I'm legitimately amazed
because I went into this I was
approaching this game because it was
highly rated on game field I looked at
it it was like a B so I'm sort of good
like some sort of well made the
screenshots did look good I will admit
it did look good but I mean now that I'm
in here I fully realized the
ramifications of what everyone was
saying when they were saying that this
game was really good this game is like
item added extras extras hey this game
is awesome
this is awesome everything about this is
so cool I don't even know what it is but
I'm having a good time
right behind me yeah maybe I can climb
up this ladder here all those fake
ladder
bows I think it could be a real ladder
here
there's another one I see over there get
over here did it my belly yeah yep got
it six eight yeah I'm gonna win somehow
I don't know how well I might win
what about the dumpsters yep there it is
don't look where it takes you I better
not look
oh he's nowhere to be found to get lost
on the things oh look it's my Jeep my
weird glowy Jeep is your page on here
your page your page oh oh maybe that's
my escape once I get all the pages for
some reason I want to escape here I
don't know why guess this place is
awesome
nope not there oh there he is he's us
he's a slip slider he's a slip sliding
all but he's stuck on stuff oh I get oh
I get it
moved Jesus that spooked me it was so
spoopy the way it's pooped all over me
who's spoo [ __ ] too much boobage okay
so they've got to be like is that the
dumpster yeah that doesn't make any
sense
let's don't make any sense
oh I thought about oh it's in there
there it is got it cool now do I just
got to get to that Jeep
and get out of here I did it guys I
can't believe this game this is my way
out cuz I could I could I could I could
I you're still here why are you still
here don't get me you followed me follow
me bro what am I supposed to do what am
I supposed to do hop in one of these
cars he's sweet rides here they ready to
maybe I just need to walk out of the
woods maybe I need to let him get me cuz
I would make sense I guess maybe a
little bit all right there your arc de
sandy boo
right there seem to be stuck on
something oh he went around it oh is
that Hey
hey sandy boo hey Slade move how you do
oh hey how are you doing oh you got a
grumpy face oh come on I went through
all of that for nothing
what was I supposed to do wait if like
if I like walk right oh I like walk
right on top of them yet well yet
cilenti boo oh yes Lindy do
Slendy do boo does he like sliding
behind me he's sliding to get behind me
if I go backwards enough hello
Slender Man slender man Knight he's
sustained by he's backing up to be
behind this game nice shadows is what
it's called so I don't know what it was
about it was so it was so bizarre in
that I've made a point not to play like
poorly made any games that I haven't
played one in a while and I kinda
remembered why I did for the longest
time I played a lot of these not
professionally weighed indie games is
because it has a sense of charm now
follow me on this one I know that a lot
of people are like game sucks but no
this game is that oh I mean it's not
well made but it's made by someone who
had a passion and just wanted to make
something and that was always what the
amazing Charma indie games was it was
because when I played it I knew that it
was one guy trying his best to do what
he could and learning experience so like
this game it's silly and it's charming
that's all it is it's like it had a
weird charm in that I totally forgot
that people do their best and it still
cannot turn out to be something
fantastic but well as I was walking
through the field and seeing the leaves
pop out I imagined how much work someone
was putting into making those leaves pop
just that way and and look that way and
you know it like put a smile on my face
because I remembered I haven't done
these indie horror games he's really
really low budget easy to do indie
horror games in a long time and all bugs
aside and not working properly aside and
that's a term to it I must seem really
stupid and giddy right now but I'm
legitimately like charmed by this it was
a silly adventure and it was cool
I had fun
time toggle thank you everybody so much
for watching give the developer of this
game some words of encouragement to keep
trying don't let anyone get him down
this game may not be the best in the
world but hey it's a start and he's
trying that's all that matters so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye